yes it's Wednesday the very best day of
the week it is the best day of the week
because this is the time that I John
Perry get to nerd out on a skull show it
to you and you the good people of the
internet get to guess what it is this is
last week's guest and a lot of you tried
to guess what this is and last time I
checked there was only one person that
identified this skull correctly youtube
user
hot dog lost fog congratulations your
prize this week is being the only person
that was right on the internet that must
feel good congratulations
now normally I'd be a little bit
disappointed if everybody got the skull
wrong like what happened this week but
it was so tricky in fact that I had to
get help before I did last week's video
I had to make sure that I knew in fact
what this thing is I'm borrowing this
skull from chintamani Wildlife Center
and they were pretty sure that it was a
stellar sea lion but nobody that I
talked to there was 100% sure and I
couldn't figure it out even like
googling images of stellar sea lion
skulls a lot of the Google results that
I was getting we're actually showing me
California sea lions instead of stellar
sea lions I had to get on Twitter and
ask professionals if they could ID this
and I did get an ID from Robert Bo's
Necker he said yes this is a female
yumoto pious which is a stellar sea lion
the giveaway is the upper cheek tooth
count and there's a big diastema between
premolar 4 and molar 1 molar one is
often somewhat posterior ly inclined as
well and so we're seeing all those
features in this skull this this is
actually really confusing because this
here is a sleeping family of stellar sea
lions and you will notice here that the
male is significantly larger than the
female and in stellar sea lions and in
California sea lions the males will
develop a sagittal crest a very distinct
crest on the top of their head it runs
along the sagittal suture and it's an
attachment for the muscles of the jaw
the temporalis muscle the the muscle of
the temple having that crest gives them
a little bit more bites
which they probably use when they're
fighting other males if you look at this
skull this skull is from a California
sea lion and it has a huge sagittal
crest huge temporal muscles there so yes
this is either a female skull or it
might be a sub-adult that's also
possible stellar sea lions by the way
live in the Northern Pacific you'll see
them on the Oregon coast but it's hard
to tell them apart from California sea
lions they're also the main sea lions
that you'll see if you're in Alaska or
they also hang out in China and I
believe even like Japan and that that
region really cool animals massive for
this week's specimen I am taking you on
a trip to a museum in Charleston and I
don't want to tell you exactly which
museum it is quite yet because I don't
want to give away what animal this is
but this creature is extinct
so this is gonna be a little bit
difficult we've been doing a lot of
tougher ones these days just fun no
googling but I am gonna give you a few
hints because this is an extinct animal
and when I say no we're gonna guess what
extinct animal this is that could open
up the door to anything from like
dinosaurs to you know whatever so this
this is not a dinosaur this is a mammal
and I want to talk a little bit real
quickly about how you can tell this is a
mammal we talked about this last time we
talked about tooth differentiation in
mammals so if you go back in the fossil
record and you look at early mammals all
of them have incisors canines premolars
and molars the incisors being the sort
of flat teeth in the front the canines
being the spiked teeth to the sides of
those incisors and then you have
premolars behind those and molars in the
back this species is actually lost a lot
of its dental differentiation but you
can still see that the canines are
larger than the incisors they're just
taller and then you can see in the
molars you get some some pretty obvious
differentiation so this thing is
actually losing some of
it's dental differentiation but it still
has it by the way the modern lineage
that this gave rise to does not have
very much dental differentiation most of
the species in the group that this thing
gave rise to all of the teeth are
identical and even though they're
mammals
so that's that's kind of a pretty big
hint don't google it the other big
giveaway that this is a mammal is the
zygomatic arch the zygomatic arch let me
just show you actually on some bones in
my office so here we are back in my
office this on a human is the zygomatic
arch it's the cheekbone and if you look
at the Bobcat that we had on the show
earlier he's got a really nice big
cheekbone and if you look at the skunk
as well look from above this huge arch
and you know other animals do have a
bone that's similar to this but it's not
there's not this giant arch the
zygomatic arch is what we call it it's
very specific to mammals and what
happens here is that behind this arch so
if we will get it in humans look closely
there you have a big muscle right here
it's a jaw muscle it's the temporalis or
the temporal muscle that the muscle of
the temple and that connects down to
this little little nub on the mandible
on the lower jaw let me show you in the
and the cat it's really obvious in the
cat it connects down to this so it goes
underneath the muscle goes underneath
the zygomatic arch and connects to this
process which is called the coronoid
process that is what powers the movement
of the jaw a lot of the movement of the
jaw and other animals like crocodiles
and so on it actually have a completely
different hinge mammals mammals jaws
hinge on this little structure here
which is called the mandibular condyle
condyle is just any round bone that fits
into
boom so the mandibular condyle is unique
in mammals other reptiles use a very
different joint and crocodiles use a
very different joint birds use a
different joint so these are different
ways that you can tell when you're
looking at a mammal hopefully what I
told you was actually informative just
now so this creature that you are seeing
is definitely a mammal it's large you
can see my hand in comparison to this
skull right here very very large animal
that's all the hints I'm gonna give you
it's a big old mammal that's extinct
what could it be
what do you think this beast is let me
know in the comments and I will be very
impressed if you figure this out without
googling it I'll be very impressed
that's it for this week's skull good
luck